all right back after a couple of weeks
of hiatus is hate reott mail
what is hatred mail it is when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings of the hate mail
that I receive here's a quick reminder
why don't you take some
hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom alright a lot in this week's
hatred mail let's listen to it first and
then discuss and think about it nice
yarmulke David of course Pakman is a Jew
Hispanic is not a race it is an
ethnicity and you're Jewish but
Argentina white boy get the Jews out
seriously David Pakman is a Jew a denier
of Christ don't be a greedy Jew and use
your dog as a ploy come on bro we're
better than that as progressives so
Hispanic is not a race but rather an
ethnicity but I'm Jewish
but I'm from Argentina so I'm a white
boy but Jews should leave well I guess
if Jews are white then I don't need to
leave it's kind of a weird amalgam of
xenophobia and various misunderstandings
I love the we're better than that as
progressives the viewer I guess sort of
implying that they are part of the
progressive crowd just another
progressive who says Jews get out
yeah somehow I think that this person
may be gaslighting and what I want to
remind you is the best way to fight hate
reott ISM is to use the coupon code hey
tree at forty when you get a membership
at join pakman.com h80
r io t 4-0 you save 40% and hey tree
it's cry every time that coupon code is
used at join pakman.com